it's great to welcome to the program
today Justin DeWitt who was the
Democratic nominee for Louisiana's 6th
congressional district in this year in
the recent midterms against the
Republican incumbent Garret graves now
Justin did not ultimately prevail in
that election but there is more to the
story as we are now learning that Justin
has been fired from his job a job that
he actually maintained throughout the
campaign which we will talk about
welcome Justin great to talk to you
thanks for having me on day four talking
with you as well so let's start at the
beginning you you run in this race
Louisiana's sixth congressional district
you're the Democratic nominee did you
have a primary which you won or on the
primary side where you want to posed we
don't have primaries what happens is
everyone's on the ballot on November 6th
that we had we have jumbled general
primaries where no matter how many
Democrats or Republicans are on the
ticket we're all in the same ticket so
it was me followed by a independent
followed by the incumbent Garret graves
and then another Democrat which I did
and secured the endorsement in August
saw with the official nominee and talked
a little bit about the district I mean I
think people generally just think of
Louisiana as very conservative even
though the truth is that there are some
progressive enclaves you do have cities
in Louisiana that tend to be more on the
left what's the kind of make up of the
6th district where you were running the
6th district if it was to be a fairs on
district and include most of the county
or parish that I'm in East Baton Rouge
it would be a majority would be a
democratic congressional district but
it's gerrymandered where it cuts out
people of minority and the Democrats
registered Democrats cuts this out and
separates us into multiple districts so
it limits the power but as a whole in my
district goes from north of the capital
city of Baton Rouge all the way down the
Mississippi River on both sides all the
way to new almost to Orleans where the
congressman Cedric Richmond District is
the only Democrat from our state comes
up from New Orleans in the middle of my
district all the way up the river to
just north Baton Rouge okay so and in
this district is also where you were
working at the time that you made the
decision to run yes I've been working at
the company I was at for four and a half
years okay and what what company was it
and what kind of work did you do there
it's name is sjb group I did a land
surveying work I've been doing that
since I was 18 years old after Hurricane
Katrina I did work in New Orleans on the
flood walls and gates and structures
like that after Katrina and I've been
doing highways and those things of that
such since my entire adult life and
worked with a company up for four and a
half years and basically I traveled
travel the country and I'm from so I've
been all over the south but I travel the
state know I'm doing highway projects
mainly highway flooding infrastructure
and things of that nature
okay and at the time that you decide to
run that you announced that you're
running which if I recall correctly is a
December December 2017 December 2017
okay the announcement so what is the
reaction from your coworkers and what is
the reaction if any from your
supervisors at your job pretty much a ha
oh that's a cool idea but we'll see what
you do with you know it's kind of that
old I'll see it when I don't believe it
when I see it kind of understand that
knee-jerk reaction from some people that
you know someone's got to run for office
you're like oh are you really or is that
you know just something you say you're
gonna do but not too big of a splash
done when I made my announcement with
them I did make the news and that was
that was a little bit more some of some
people were like okay this is gonna be
something here to it let's see if you uh
stick through with it and as you start
campaigning do you take time off do you
have long periods of absence from your
job or do you sort of manage to continue
doing the job and campaign
simultaneously I maintain working the
entire time I did take off a few days
like here and there one or two one or
two days at a time when we had to
qualified our name officially on the
ballot in July I took two days off of
that maybe took a day or so if I
remember correctly between January and I
did so I went to Washington for a
four-day trip I took two days of
vacation where we only worked for ten so
Friday I'm already off by happy we're
already off on Friday so I take like a
Monday
to make it a long weekend to get things
I need to do done in a four-day period
and did you have any of what we would
call we call them this in in on the
David Pakman show when we just never
hear from a guest and they're just not
on skype we call it a no call no show
we're basically with no explanation no
advance notice you're just not there
when you're expected to be there
oh no I've never no call no show his
automatic termination most companies
that I've worked for my life and I've
never had a no call no show the only
time that me and like normal any
employee would do is some medical
emergency had happened which I have I
think that was in 2017 I had one of
those happened where my husband was at a
medical emergency and I wasn't able to
call my company until about nine or ten
o'clock in the morning we're supposed to
be at work at 7:00 a.m. but I've never
had a no-call notion understood
so before let me let me walk through it
before the end of the campaign did you
ever have any conversations where
supervisors would pull you aside or want
to have conversations related to the
campaign your presence within the office
or anything like that uh about March or
so of 2018 my supervisor pulled me
inside or called me actually and told me
because I'd left left that day already
and he was just getting to it gave me a
call and said needed to stop the talking
about politics at work if we've had some
complaints which I that came as a
surprise to me because I don't talk work
politics at work I'll get a phone call
or something on my lunch break and I'll
you know talk to someone and then I
would excuse me another co-worker who
might ask Oh what was that about or hey
I saw you on the news I talked to them
when they engaged me but I never engaged
people in politics that were not without
them engaging me first it was never a
hey let's talk about this whether you
want to or not no it was always them
asking me questions that led to a
conversation and had there was there any
disciplinary action for that or you were
just told some papers on your local
politics it was a verbal thing it wasn't
really disciplinary it was more of a hey
I'm giving you a heads-up so this isn't
a problem but that was the first thing
that happened and then qualifying
happened and after that it became a
little bit more evident that I was
making a I guess I was getting a little
bit more popular there was no answer
people didn't like it as much and so
Election Day ultimately rolls around you
you do end up not not victorious you
plan to get back to work and then what
happens well October 26th was to be I
was 26 was to be my last day at work for
a 8 day period I was taken off in order
to finish out the election and get right
out to vote get out to vote and all that
stuff really hit the heart the campaign
trail hard for the last few week or so
and so I took eight days off vacation
and that Tuesday night November 6 was
the election Wednesday was a day of
relax and recover and then Thursday I
was supposed to go back to work that uh
eighth suppose go back then I received a
phone call for my employer saying that
they were downsizing and that they were
gonna have to terminate me that I am
laid off because of their numbers
they're reducing their numbers as well
as they are they've had complaints about
me or something like that like you know
you have a complaints on you and
relaying you all okay so now let me see
if I understand that
is it a layoff or is it a firing because
of complaints well it's a layoff is what
they're calling you and then there's
their leg may be chosen because of the
complaints that that's pretty much what
they made it out to sound like and but
the thing about it is I never had any
complaints four and a half years there
you think you would have a got rid of me
if I was a problem before that and the
other thing was that they're not cutting
down I mean we have six trucks that were
going out every day of crews each crew
crew is a two-man thing so in order to
reduce your numbers and lower your
overhead costs you would have to lay me
off in my assistant model my main
well when I understand I'm the only one
they got the boot so yeah that was gonna
be my next question which is did it so
this was this was layoffs was anyone
else laid off no no and in terms of
within your position how did your
seniority rank compared to others well I
was hired in June of 2014 in this
company and
everyone else there is there now was
hired after me so I was the most senior
field surveyor that they had as far as
working for this company goes so now
there may have had they said that this
is a layoff and the only person laid off
is you and you happen to be one of the
more senior people that's doing the job
that you're doing so something doesn't
sound quite right right and the timing
of 36 hours after the polls closed you
lay me off that doesn't make sense
either so what do you think happened do
you think this is that they disagree
with your politics or do you think they
just don't like that you were running
for office and it's not about your
politics per se they found that the
campaign was a distraction if I had to
take a yes to put a title on or put
something on and I'd say that being in
the field that I'm in my opponent the
noise less in this election gear graves
family as an engineering firm as well
and we have State engineering boards
that oversee all surveying and all
engineers in our state and Garret is
supposedly the one getting these
projects and stuff like that which the
projects he claims to have gotten help
which was really not money it's loans
$509 loan to do an interstate expansion
the company I work for was doing that
survey work we were doing the survey
work for the majority of the dotd
projects and majority of the middle
majority of the projects that Garrett
claims to have gotten so if I had to put
something on it I'd say that I'm a
liability of a black mark on their their
platform when they go to bid on these
projects so you know can't you're
bidding on the projects that a guy gets
in Congress that claims he got in
Congress and you have the guy that ran
against him on the payroll staff don't
think they like that so have you spoken
to a lawyer about whether you might have
any recourse and the reason I ask is
number one even if it were your
political beliefs that got you fired
political orientation affiliation is not
a protected class period you mentioned
your husband in Louisiana it happens
also that sexual orientation is not a
protected class for the purposes of
employment so even if you suspected that
that may have played a role it doesn't
it's not really clear that that
would be an area of recourse so what
what is what is your next step here is
this just it well actually in state
Louisiana right with the sexual
orientation is not protected your boss
can walk in and say you're gay you're
fired
there's no repercussion but actually we
do have statues on our rule laws on a
state level that protect you from being
terminated for political purposes when
you run for an office or being that
you're engaged in any political
organization we have protection there's
a few statutes that I'm using that I
went to I'm talking to the district
attorney's office about filing charges
against the company for terminating me I
do not have the number in front of me
but I might be able to get it what is it
SB o RS RS 23 nine sixty one under
Louisiana state law is a statute that I
point to that is pretty much the exact
same case here that someone else has
used this statute as well back in 1981 I
believe that you don't fire someone
during election after right after an
election or for political purposes
that's forbidden under our state law now
what will ultimately be at issue is
whether it can be proven that that was
the reason for the firing and I'm
wondering if they have created a paper
trail to justify these so-called
complaints that they mentioned in order
to be able to say hey you know what
there's no evidence that this was for
political reasons it's because of these
complaints and we have a record of them
here do you suspect that that's what
they may do well I mean there's anybody
trying to cover their tracks they
probably would do that but fortunately I
have my as well paper trail of getting a
bonus back in October for performance
and as well as getting a job performance
raise in July so my performance in July
was good enough to get a raise my
performance in October October fourth or
fifth was good enough to get a
profit-sharing bonus but there's
complaints against me that I need to be
laid off those don't add up as well as
every time someone ever in this
political process I've learned how dirty
politics are so I have paid attention
every time someone talks to me in the
way they talk to me and the things they
mean to say or they're nothing to say
the way they say things so I've watched
my back and I've watched how people act
when I say things to them so I pretty
much I've kept my nose clean and they
can try to cover up with the paper trail
but evidence would be against them on
that one
all right well something definitely
doesn't sound right we've been speaking
with Justin DeWitt who ran for
Louisiana's sixth congressional district
did not come out victorious but now has
been fired within 36 hours of polls
closing by his employer Justin please
let us know how what what ultimately
happens well currently my staff has
gotten together they put me a GoFundMe
account up right now to help me get by
for now as well as I'm looking forward
to this next year working with people
who are running for our state
legislature in our state Senate in
Louisiana in order to get people in
there they're going to change working
walls number one we're at will state and
that's that's got a sunset that's got to
go away as well as I look forward to
doing what I can to help our governor
get reelected in Louisiana because our
governor actually stands up for the
workers in Louisiana he's stood up for
the LBGT stood up for everybody he can
he doesn't stand up for the corporate
interest he stands up for the people so
mine next year hopefully involves a lot
more getting involved with helping other
people win political office Justin
thanks so much for your time today thank
you